so you started doing zooms for a
thousand people
a number of months ago and that must
have been a real adaptation i'm just
gonna try and [ __ ] from you and maybe
there are some folks who are watching
this that actually want to
like what are the best practices if
you're actually going to do
uh zoom comedy show for a thousand
people because that must be a lift
it's not that hard it's just a lot of
leg work
up front and then basically it's
don't touch anything once you have the
lighting in place and your levels are in
place
just don't touch it uh but yeah and
and and i have to say like my friend sam
marielle is a comedian he's the one who
said
you should try it and the reason in the
convincing argument this
is way back in june i was like ah
doesn't seem like it's for me feels like
a hell gig to use the word that i used
in my vulture article
and he said he goes you know what's
really interesting he goes
the people who show up aren't just
people
who are homebound from covid
there are people who are homebound just
from
medical conditions in their life to
begin with
who would never go to a comedy show ever
and i thought oh well that's reason
enough i mean i
then i should try argument yeah i mean i
should try to crack this because
if we're if there's a whole group of
people who have medical conditions that
are keeping them away from live
performance
let me let's try to crack live
[Music]
performance
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks today we've
got an incredibly
exciting episode we've got mike
berbiglia the comedian on which
i love we have comedians on because you
know it's going to be funny
so you guys are going to have a blast of
the sit back lats
and have a good laugh with andrew i know
you will enjoy it
but first i wanted to do a little
crowing
what everybody is talking about this
week is what the hell is happening
with robin hood and gamestop
and our stock market right now on wall
street because it's going berserk
and i saw meme on there that said like
this is a really great time for people
who love to explain things
and uh you're not wrong because it's
complicated
but it's also freaking hilarious to the
point where
david portnoy from barstool donald trump
jr
aoc and ted cruz are all aligned on how
absurd this is and how terrible it is um
so i wanted to talk about that but to
crow before we start
for those of you who listen back on new
year's day we did an episode
of yank speaks and we brought on we had
myself we had andrew and we brought on
our former finance director carly riley
to give some bold predictions
for 2021 and a certain someone named
carly
predicted that robin hood would cause a
financial crisis
and here we are we're recording this 29
days later
and it's happened already she was spot
on so i wanted to bring back the
oracle herself carly riley back on this
pod just to kind of crow a little bit
and also explain so carly
you were spot on welcome welcome back
you got a lot of heat on twitter for
this they're like carly what are you
talking about a lot of people didn't
know what robin hood was
are you feeling like you're did you buy
a lottery ticket after this like
uh extra insightful are you betting now
like what's going on
well part of my point is that trading in
the stock market
uh is always a bit like glorified
gambling so uh
fair enough so uh i didn't need to buy a
lottery ticket i'm still riding
the market i'm in the market so carly
if you can maybe help us explain this
for idiots like me
i'm seeing memes of gamestop and robin
hood and something called
wall street bets um i don't understand
them so take us from the start like what
the heck
is happening yeah so
we could start either on the the reddit
wall street vet side or you can start on
the institutional
hedge fund side because at its core this
is really a
a war between the internet
and internet populism and wall street
yeah
the people burst the money in many ways
yeah and i think what's so cool and so
interesting
about this and frankly what's probably
interesting to to a lot of yang fans
is this is this is playing out in all
sorts of
industries like this is happening in
politics like andrew yang's success
was a story of internet populism against
the establishment
um and you take it industry by industry
right in in media
in politics this is now obviously
hitting wall street that's what you're
talking about
but so to take it back i i you know i
think a lot of yang speaks listeners
actually probably are
are more familiar with what's happening
with gamestop than probably your your
average probably right but it's still
fun to talk about it's still fun to talk
about i mean this whole thing is
is i have concerns about it but it's
it's just it's so fun
um it's so funny um
so a lot of hedge funds were short a
stock called
gamestop now what does short mean yeah
so short means basically they were
betting
that this stock would go down in price
instead of
buying a stock you can borrow it and
sell it immediately
at that price and then you have to buy
the shares back and ideally you're
buying them later
so you made a profit but the idea is
you're betting on a stock to go down
that's what a lot of these hedge funds
did they do it all the time right but
gamestop was one they had been shorting
very very heavily this is actually the
most shorted stock of all time
140 percent of the stock was shorted
don't ask me how it works
and that's because of corona it's a
retail store
everything's closed people buying
internet buying video games online on
xbox you don't need it that
sort of thing so game stock was widely
considered to be
not a good company to own so you have a
couple things then happening on the
internet side
there's this subreddit called wall
street bets right and it's a community
of people who
like a lot of folks on reddit love memes
love that that kind of internet culture
there's also a lot of really smart
people on there too
right and so that there's two parts of
this story there was a legitimate thesis
floating around
about why gamestop in particular
probably wasn't deserving all the
shorting it was getting and that thesis
was essentially that ryan cohen
the former founder of chewie who made
like online sales of
dog pet food a thing had bought heavily
into gamestop about a year ago and was
starting to acquire board seats etc so
there was this turnaround story that was
starting to
to gain traction on the internet there
was a smarter thesis as to why gamestop
might actually do well
then there's the second piece of it
which a bunch of guys on the subreddit
and women
i would imagine started to see what were
the stocks that
that hedge funds were shorting the most
we're betting the most against
and so and to be clear if a stock
doesn't go down
like if you if you bet if you short a
stock and instead of it going down if
you're wrong and the stock goes up
theoretically it can go up to infinity
so you can lose
infinity money right there's no ceiling
in terms of how much you can lose so if
you really want to
lose money in the stock market usually
it's when you're shorting stocks so so
this group online
started to get behind gamestop both for
reasons that they thought were
because i thought fundamentally it was a
better stock than the market was
suggesting
and also because they saw this very
clear opportunity to stick it to these
hedge funds that had been shorting the
stock and basically
make the stock go up instead of down
which is uh which is the opposite of
what the hedge funds wanted
so this starts to get traction on this
subreddit which now is up to three
million plus users and people start
buying gamestop
in mass which of course drives the price
up and this gets into exactly what zach
says the mechanics of this are basically
it started going up so much
and and nobody was really selling the
stock
to the point that the hedge funds
couldn't buy back the shares they were
borrowing or if they
were going to buy them back they were
gonna have to buy them back at really
high prices
which was you know it truly bankrupted
some of these hedge funds
so that's called a short squeeze
essentially the internet short squeezed
some of the biggest hedge funds in the
country
and it's this
they have to put take out a loan they've
lost 141 percent of their investment
they've lost more money than in the fund
itself sorry that 104 i think is of
their total assets like it's they've
lost more money on this one investment
than they have
in the fund and what's the name of this
fund i can't remember any of it it's uh
melvin capital and then citadel they
gave them a loan
and they lost the loan um so anyhow so
that's the crux of what has happened and
what people are talking about right now
and
and for i'm assuming most people are
seeing people sharing this because it
really is this like
amazing story of these internet trolls
who stuck it to the wall street clowns
and there's a couple things about this
that i think um are worth talking about
one
is wall street is freaking out over this
and
they're alleging market manipulation by
the on the part of the subreddit
they're losing their minds and it's
beautiful
they're they're calling for regulation
and i think this is what is so
frustrating to so many people and what's
frankly uniting um
you know elements of the the populist
left and and elements of the populist
right
is just the hypocrisy of that of saying
are you freaking kidding me the
the best tweet that i saw was oh no the
wrong people are manipulating the stock
market
hedge funds manipulate the stock market
every
this is what they do this is the game
the game
investing in stocks is so rigged at this
point and this can take us into the
robinhood stuff but
that the idea that they're going to
accuse this subreddit which was doing
this publicly everybody had access to
this information
you know read it having really
democratized this is so unbelievably
hypocritical
and so it just makes it extra fun to
watch them lose because
you're squirming one of them went on
cnbc and talked about how there's an
attack on the wealthy you're like
yeah it is an attack on the wealthy
screw you especially wealth where it's
just like
paper wealth you know or they're just
manipulating a game that only the rich
can play and the richest of the rich get
to win
um anyway so that was number one where
it's like
boohoo wall street so as a former a
recovering wall street analyst
boohoo you've got and by the way these
people
they will be fine they will be fine well
and this actually gets they'll sell
their third home
the other piece that's really important
to talk about which is it's fun to
celebrate this and again i think that
the nuances of this story are what make
it so fun
i think a lot like there were a number
of people on the subreddit on wall
street beds talking about how they had
automatic sell orders on
at the price of four 2069. basically the
people who took down
like citadel or are like making 420 and
sex
jokes like in the process of doing it
like they are internet trolls and it's
it's so glorious um but but i think the
the part of this that's important that i
see being missed in some of this is like
most of these hedge funds and these
hedge fund guys are are
fine because they're also playing with
other people's money these folks are
getting their two percent
commission on all their assets under
management no matter what
and frankly when when the market does go
to berserk and when it does like
eventually fully crash because i think
there's no doubt we're in a bubble right
now um which is really what i was
speaking to in many ways when i talked
about the robin hood situation back in
december
like when the market crashes it's you
know it's always everyday people who are
left holding the bag
somehow someway wall street ends up
being
fine um and i think that's what scares
me about this
right is there are a lot of [ __ ] smart
folks who were on the subreddit and
betting in
in gamestop but you also folks who are
who are newer investors who don't
necessarily know what they're doing who
are betting in it who are
we're going to be really hurt if this
thing collapses how does robinhood fit
into this
robin hood is the platform by which many
of these traders and traders like myself
execute and buy or sell gamestop and a
number of other stocks it's the
preferred
investment tool a trading app for for
young people exactly
for wall street yeah and for wall street
that's specifically right and and robin
hood's whole
premise was that they were democratizing
trading because they really introduced
this idea of commission free trades so
when i was 20 years old and couldn't
afford to trade on
ameritrade because i didn't have money
and i wasn't going to pay whatever the
commission was every time i wanted to
mess around buy shake shacks i liked
their burgers like
i got on robin hood right but that comes
at a cost right like if you're not
you're never actually talking about this
back right like if you're not paying for
the product you are the product
yes if it's free you are the you're not
the customer
you're the product you're getting they
are making money off of you
and so robin hood the way they make
money right
is they sell your trades my trades
to people on wall street to execute
those trades there's a number of ways
they make money they make more money if
you trade on margin and they make more
money if you trade options which are
both
much much riskier which is also what i
was calling blowing the whistle on back
in december because that scares me
because you have folks now trading
gamestop which is a you know a volatile
stock
and they're trading it on margin so they
sell your trades my trades to wall
street to execute those trades
and there are folks on wall street who
get a glimpse then at what trades need
to be executed
before they actually execute them which
means they see which direction
they say oh a bunch of people are buying
this we're selling that and they can
jump
jump the line and in fractions of a
second buy the stock
before the market moves um so that's
just one of the ways that this system is
rigged
it's illegal to do this in gambling um
but it's not like you'll do in the stock
market yeah high frequency trading
that's okay which is really what we're
talking about here so robin hood the
trading platform
for the people right democratizing as i
said democratizing trading and wall
street
stock market uh bets whatever you
call it
because of wall street bets that goes
viral everybody starts buying games
gamestop elon musk hops on there and is
like game stalks like hammering it like
buying like and paying money to
to jack it up because that same hedge
fund has shorted elon musk and short of
tesla
um so that like all these people get
involved um
game stops going through the roof and
everybody who's doing it generally
speaking the vast majority are buying
game stop
through robin hood so robin hood and
there's other stops too it's
amc the movie theaters it's bed bath
beyond there's like 13 stocks
and so robin hood sees this crazy
volatility
and volume of people buying these 13
stocks
and then what happens there and this is
what i'd love to ask you what happened
so at some point
robin hood stopped letting you buy those
stocks
is that correct is that what happened
that is 100 correct
there's a lot to be made of this so it's
worth noting too
that i think it was march 13th the day
like during the pandemic
when the market dropped whatever
trillion percent
it dropped robin hood training shut down
then too
and they claimed there were glitches
they came whatever if you are somebody
who was buying stuff that was the single
best day
to get into the market so already there
was something people felt like this
feels really suspicious
or just odd that on the single best day
to buy in the market
people who who get into the market
through robinhood can't participate
so then more recently fast forward and
robin hood very explicitly
basically shut down buying for
these high volatility stocks that they
were referring to then you know like
gamestop and said basically all you can
do
is sell these stocks okay there's a
couple things here my initial reaction
to this was like
mind blowing like fury and like
oh my god like just start the revolution
because
what it appears to be on the surface is
holy [ __ ] you're basically saying
everyone needs to liquidate their
position which is exactly what the hedge
funds need and want
right because again hedge funds need to
buy back the shares they borrowed
in order to make good on their their
commitments to banks and people that
they borrowed the stock from so they
need to be able to buy these shares back
they need people
to be selling gamestop right and this is
basically robin said okay
all you can do is sell gamestop my mind
explodes because i'm like
this feels like the most rigged thing
i've ever seen in my entire life
being the rational yang gang person that
i am i'm actively trying to understand
if there are other
excuses or justifications that robinhood
is able to give for why this is
happening and and this is what i'm still
trying to understand and
frankly i'd crowdsource this and say for
those who who maybe have a grasp on this
please feel free to share
on twitter wherever tweet it me zach um
i saw a really good threat today that i
haven't dug enough into but
but basically you know there are risks
to robin hood in terms of like capital
they have to put up
they'll go short-term when the
volatility gets that big and you
they truly were facing scenarios
potentially again this could all be just
what's being said but that they were
potentially facing scenarios the
volatility this high
um that that they weren't going to be
able to cover certain trades and
you know it was going to basically mess
up the whole system i'm not articulating
this well if you can articulate it
better tell me
no alex i think so robin hood basically
halted trading so the democratizing
trading
was bs when the going was good when the
people were actually winning like they
stopped
and robin hood is a major wall street
player
they serve the certain masters and they
are not democratized their ceo did the
rounds on the
cable news tv the other night and chris
cuomo
i thought ripped him apart and i'm not i
like chris cuomo um
but i think he rips people harder than
others at times but he was great i
thought
um saying that you're you're full of it
dude like you
and this guy is a dude um and he's up
there saying like oh we had a lot of
volatility and like we couldn't
you know it's not good for our customers
no dude you're going broke
because you serve wall street the way
they were you know the same way you were
losing my same way they were
so that's really interesting i didn't
realize that he had publicly gone out
and
and justified this as saying it was
because of high volatility oh yeah it
was saying like this unprecedented
market volatility and by the way
and that's what chris coleman said this
is the job of the stock market
not the broker like the new york stock
exchange job as a cult trading not the
brokers and that's with bs about it
yeah and look i don't understand why if
this issue was about them not being able
to cover the differences or whatever
like why they would only halt
buying and not selling and if the ceo is
out there trying to pretend he's doing
this for the good of people
that is the biggest that that truly
people should go to jail if this was not
about truly
that they they just didn't have the
capacity or the whatever to handle this
volume of trades or whatever the heck
they could potentially claim to justify
it people should belong in jail this is
absolutely outrageous and um
you know i don't understand legally how
that would work please tell me but like
the idea that you are going to shut down
uh retail investors because the hedge
funds don't like it
the irony of the hedge funds calling for
regulation on this stuff
it makes me want to just like when is
elon musk calling using mars like get me
out of here it is it is
it is so frustrating so again two parts
of this very frustrating parts very fun
parts where you can enjoy some of the
meme culture that's
emanating from this as a yang yang
supporter
i hope all of you are hammering this on
twitter and loving it on instagram like
anywhere you see it like
champion the people i don't i will not
and we are not recommending you buy
gamestop like i don't think these are
particularly good investments at the
moment i think it's crazy but if you
have cash to burn
to stick it to a little extra cash uh
then you're not donating to certain
political endeavors
um but if you have cash burn and you
want to stick it to a hedge fund guys
have at it
um and yang tweeted this and i agree uh
we were talking about the other days
that gamestop has changed the game
forever
forever wall street will have to answer
to the people because of how the
internet's aligned now i don't know what
this means going forward
no one does the regulators who don't
represent us
are going to try and stop it um but
carly riley 29 days in you were right
congratulations y'all bow to you for a
quick
you can get my i'll tip my cap or
whatever a day okay i'm gonna beat you
in the long run on this thing um
but it's amazing i hope that guys look
broke that down for you if you want to
tweet at us and give us more insight
the situation will have evolved by
monday when this airs but regardless
it's been joyful in 2020 it's been
hilarious
carly thank you for joining thank you a
pleasure as always
your expertise you're now the robin hood
expert any time we talk about robin hood
the funny position i found myself in
wasn't seeing that coming for i didn't
think so either once again
uh here we are cool anyway guys mike
forbiglia
the comedian joining yang speaks have
some fun have a few laughs
take a listen
[Music]
as usual guys this podcast is brought to
you by athletic greens
the most comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage i've tried i had it this
morning it's great i love it
i love it after eating spicy food so i'd
like a spicy pizza last night i had
athletic greens this morning
felt really great 75 vitamins minerals
and whole food source ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend
and more literally everything is in this
freaking thing which is awesome they all
work together to fill in the gaps in
your diet
they increase your energy and focus and
for me i do feel a little more energetic
and a little more focused when i take it
and it helps the digestion and your
immune system
which we all need what's exciting about
us is if you buy athletic
greens today we're gonna give you a free
one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase with us if you visit our
link today so all you gotta do
is visit athleticgreens.com yang join
health experts athletes health conscious
go-getters like me kind of
making the commitment to their health
every day that's athleticgreens.comyang
get your free supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
i am so pumped to interview for yang
speaks
for the very first time world class
comedian thinker artist dramatist
filmmaker mike berbiglia mike welcome
oh my gosh wow that's the most applause
i've gotten in nine months
no i can't believe it because you're a
family man like me and i'm sure every
time you come home
your wife and daughter are like yay
daddy's yes
oh yes of course i forgot about that i
forgot about that
that's the way they greet me mike i get
home yeah um actually when i get home
everyone
completely [ __ ] ignores me
[Laughter]
no i mean uh the pandemic has really
driven home a lot of specific uh
family roles and uh
my role is to figure out how to be a
live comedian
as a job when you can't perform in front
of
people and i've done that by having my
podcast working it out
and doing working it out virtually where
i do live virtual shows for i'm not
kidding andrew
thousands of people that's incredible
like on
valentine's weekend i'm doing five shows
a thousand people
per show the final show we're giving a
hundred percent of the proceeds
to uh food banks which is what we do
with uh
the one of each series of shows
we give to food banks because as i can
tell you're
you're more educated in this than i am
but it seems like food banks
are are a good place to donate money
right now
they're a great place to donate money
and uh thank you for doing it
now that is awesome that you have such a
following that you can
have a show for thousands online um
i think you may be singular in this
capacity because i i
mean i do know other comedians but i've
not heard of any of them doing anything
uh like that at that level um it must
have been an enormous adjustment for you
like what was your first zoom
performance like
because that must have been very very uh
difficult
must have felt like a real reach um you
know
and the first time you did it you would
be like hey is this gonna suck are
people
gonna be like grumpy that there was
actually money involved
that was a huge concern i remember
it was in the first thing i did in the
virtual space was
i i i i actually wrote about this for
vulture
this week i wrote this this piece called
hell gig and it's all about
when you start out in comedy you're
performing in bowling alleys and
gymnasiums and cafeterias and like
literally anywhere
which by the way running for president i
imagine you find yourself
in some health in bowling alleys yes and
yeah yeah like
nightclubs yeah i mean i mean it's not
that dissimilar and uh and so
in the world of virtuals it's similarly
sort of a hell gig
it's like it's not the best sound
quality it's not the best lighting it's
not the best way to
connect but what i found was is uh i was
driving
to a comedy club in march and
listening to npr the epidemiologist and
they were going you know
uh this isn't looking great
that first hint of like this i remember
those early days in march
it felt like a zombie movie yes where
you're getting the news reports being
like
and like this is shutting down and yeah
you might wanna
like up yeah like those were very very
yeah the toilet paper days
yeah the where do you have enough toilet
paper
days of the pandemic and uh i was
driving to a club in buffalo
and i got halfway there i got to ithaca
new york
which uh which is a great town and you
were driving from brooklyn at the time
yeah from brooklyn where i live in
brooklyn and uh and then i
sat i went i remember this really well i
always loved to go to local pizzerias so
in ithaca there's a place called
thompson and bleeker and it's phenomenal
and they have a communal table because i
was alone so i'm just like
eating with strangers and uh
and they said we're getting worried
about this
virus we were listening to joe rogan
and he's where and i go and i in my in
that for me
i was like i'm going home they were like
i was like
to me when the venn diagram of joe rogan
matches up with npr it means there's
something of a national consensus
and i'm out and then the first virtual
thing i did was
me and roy wood jr got on the phone and
we said what can we do for comedy club
wait staff because this is gonna mean
no job a total wipeout yeah and so we
came up with this thing called tip your
weight staff it still exists tip your
weightstaff.com
which all it is it's not you know i
don't have a non-profit
it just houses uh gofundmes
for comedy club wait staffs across the
country and
cumulatively they've raised about
three-quarters of a million dollars
that's incredible
thanks oh applause again from the yang
family
yes welcome home dad
[Laughter]
but like but i will say like i i think
that's where
some of your interests and my interests
intersect and why i
really respected you as a presidential
candidate i'm convinced that the
parallels between comedians
and politicians are sky high and i can
describe my day-to-day
life as a candidate which would be
incredibly familiar to you it's one
reason why i
like comedians and get on well with many
of your colleagues i feel like you get
america you get people
in like a different way than other folks
because like you've seen so much of the
country
you've been in front of crowds of like
completely different types of people in
different
places at night they just come to have a
good time
yeah i mean i always make this joke that
people call me on social media
a coastal elite just because i live on a
coast and i'm better than other people
and and then i but i point out like i'm
not a co i'm quintessentially not a
coastal elite
how many people do you know have lived
and
you know performed and worked in 45
states for god's sakes like i've
i've seen the whole country i'm not i'm
not uh
i'm not cut off from people's lives no
you you can't be and even your
description of what for you is like a
fairly normal gig is like hey
i'm gonna drive to buffalo now i'm gonna
stop in ithaca get my like pizza fix
on the way and then drive another three
hours and then perform in buffalo and
then
stay overnight in buffalo and then maybe
do another like you know i mean that's
like just
normal stuff at least in good times um
and for me running for president it was
wild mike because there were
a few different things i was trying to
make happen at once but a lot of it
revolved around whether i could get
people in iowa new hampshire
behind me and so i would be in iowa new
hampshire and anyone who would have me
i would be there it'd be like hey you
know we're having like a backward
barbecue there like hey i'm
like i would just show up and and then i
would you know talk about
uh like automation and my vision and the
rest of it
um and it was i think very similar to
what
uh performers or comedians would do is
where you go to a small town there's a
small crowd and like you kind of work
your way up
um and and so i had to work my way up in
those
environments and i used to tell people
and this was more or less true i was
like one iowan or one new hampshire
um voter uh was like worth like a
thousand
californians was my joke that's very
funny
yes and it is it's pretty close yeah
it was pretty accurate um so if i went
to an iowa backyard barbecue and there
are six people there i'd be like six
thousand californians
yeah no i mean my experience of driving
through the country
over the years i mean i've been on the
road for 20 years you know like i i
started
at 22 driving around the country my
mom's beat up volvo station wagon i put
about a hundred
something thousand miles on that car and
uh
my experience has been like i when trump
came along
i was not surprised that his message
of american carnage and all that stuff
was resonating
because i was i was seeing the country
and going like this country's really
struggling
so he's speaking to a thing the problem
is
the way that a snake oil salesman does
he was selling a thing that doesn't fix
the problem
yeah i had the same experience running a
non-profit
i started called venture for america not
as broadly as you where i didn't go to
45 states but i
went to maybe 18 states including
alabama louisiana missouri
ohio michigan and i saw the struggles
and it's one reason why i became
convinced that we needed to think bigger
about what an economic
solution could look like uh and
especially when you looked at the towns
that had gotten completely blasted by
the decimation of manufacturing jobs
like you go there
and so like i'm a serial entrepreneur
and i was running an entrepreneurship
organization
and entrepreneurs are generally very can
do and positive so you're like hey you
know let's do something and start
businesses
it's like make something positive happen
and you'd go to a depressed area the
midwest and the south and you would just
feel like
like like hey whatever i was going to
say like
i should probably rethink it for this
particular group and environment
totally absolutely being a road comedian
over the years
seeing the country has actually been
great as an artist
because it's forced me similar to what
you're saying it's forced me to
focus on what's human about what i'm
saying instead of what's
referential what's a cultural reference
that might play in new york
you know they always say like you know
new york comedians will show up places
sometimes if they're too insular
and they'll talk about the subway for 20
minutes and people are like i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
and it is good to sort of see the
country and understand like
what people's lives are like yeah
completely
and that that was what drove me
um i'm convinced that eventually a
comedian is going to run for office very
very successfully
um so i don't know if it's going to be
you mike i don't know it's gonna be
someone else i don't think i have a
thick enough skin
you folks take such a hit
in this way that's so personal i find
they take such personal shots at you and
i feel like it's so unfair
well i guess you would understand it
better than most uh you know as someone
who
puts yourself out there all the time um
certainly
i do feel a lot of respect for folks who
run for office because they do take a
lot of shots i think it is
worse for women uh you know i think yeah
for sure
it's worse for um people of color or
pretty much any marginalized group
um but yeah it's it's rough and like
because you're running for office people
have a license to
uh say whatever they want to love about
you more or less so that you you're
you know you have to uh take it in
stride
i was just gonna make a sports reference
that if you had like a number one draft
pick
sure for comedian as political figure
like someone who could like run for u.s
senate
and for people think about this like al
franken
yeah uh did it out of minnesota like he
was yeah snl comedian
very very smart yeah you know like
served as a senator for a long time
so this to me is more or less inevitable
that there's going to be a high level
yes i think you're right
i think you're right i think that john i
think like john mulaney or dave
chappelle or
ali wong could run and just
just by virtue of their pure skill with
people
would have a ton of traction right out
of the gate so certainly dave
that's for sure certainly dave um john
mulaney
makes sense to me um allie wong
also makes sense to me i hadn't thought
of her but that's a great great
suggestion yeah
now i guess those can be the top three
draft picks
i mean i mean you put you could put me
in the mix at one point when trump was
when trump was first elected in 16 we
my wife and i were in such a spiral of
like
what the hell is going to happen to the
country that i literally said
i may have to run for public office and
i and it wasn't
out of any sense of i wanted to it was
it wasn't everybody's sense of desire no
it was completely
obligation it was simply like someone
has to do
something this is a debacle and that's
when i actually started doing this whole
thing called
i started doing a tour called stand up
and vote and we go to colleges and we
put on essentially free shows we give
the proceeds to
head count and rock the vote and
vote.org
and it was like you know we've had you
know john legend and we've had roy wood
junior and we've
in jon stewart did one of them he came
to princeton with us and
you know we've had like all these great
people we're going to do it again in 22
we're going to do it again in 24. i mean
like
i mean i think voting
i think one of the upsides of this
election in 20
is the voter participation being so high
and then i think that one of the things
that's scary is how many votes trump got
it's awesome you got activated mike i
mean i felt the same way like i never
would have run for president if trump
hadn't won in 16.
um and you and i were in touch uh around
trying to activate voters in georgia
like when we're trying to flip the
senate and
you know you're trying to activate young
people um so
it's awesome that you've driven so much
energy
um to voting among young people who we
all know don't vote at the same levels
as
uh we we'd like in a lot of cases
[Music]
new sponsor alert is called candid and
what do they do
they fix your smile it's freaking
awesome so look
when i was a kid i got braces i got them
from sixth grade to eighth grade
i hated braces i had little buck teeth
well that they weren't little they had
big buck teeth
the rest teeth were little i looked
terrible and they took forever and it's
expensive you don't even know what
you're paying for
so with candid you don't have to go the
orthodontist
but you can get an expert in tooth
movement you can fix your smile however
you like and you could do it from the
convenience of your own
home it's super exciting a lot of these
companies only use like general dentists
this is only orthodontist they
specialize in teeth movement
they specialize in smiles and the
average treatment is only like six
months so they'll see results way before
then
and it'll be thousands of dollars less
than traditional braces we love this and
the best part
is we got a discount for you we want you
to become your best you
your best smile so start straightening
your teeth today and right now you can
save 75
bucks 75 on the candid starter kit which
very cool so you got to go to
dot candidco.com slash yang and use that
code yang save 75 bucks on your starter
kit
candidco.com use the code yang
have a beautiful teeth don't be like me
in middle school oh my gosh
[Music]
if dave ran for like ohio senate he'd
probably win that thing
i think i think he'd win for sure yeah
no i agree with you about chappelle in
ohio i mean i feel like
that would be open and shut case i think
he could run for anything in ohio
because he's lived there for 20 plus
years i he you know dave is the first
guy ever i ever opened for at the
washington dc improv
really yeah so you were a georgetown
student
did you just like show up and do do an
improv because dad has
deep roots in dc obviously yep so i i i
i
uh my freshman year i showed up at
georgetown
uh and i i had i'd wanted to go to
harvard
because it to follow in the footsteps of
like conan o'brien
like i always thought like that's you go
to the heart you write for the harvard
lampoon
and i thought and then i got and you
know and then i got rejected from
harvard
i actually had a ridiculous interview
for harvard
where the woman who was interviewing me
goes like why would you why do you want
to go to harvard and i go
i want to write for the harvard lampoon
and i pull out
a binder of comedy writing i had
developed over four years this would
either be a home run
or a total strikeout depending upon the
interviewer
she was a she was a lawyer she had
no interest in humor whatsoever
she and then and then this is put the
nails in the coffin she goes uh
is there any other reason you want to go
to harvard other than to write for the
harvard lampoon
and i said uh no that's the main reason
and
and so and clearly it's a huge mistake
it's a huge
tactical error but it was honest
you had passion you had direction you
had a clear vision
i love it except this young man um like
that's where i would have gone but then
i went to georgetown and i was i
auditioned for the improv group i got in
i i spent four years with those guys
including like nick kroll who i
i cast in the improv group and he cast
john mullaney so there was like a
lineage of
jack and jaclyn novak too so there's
like a really bunch
good bunch of comedians who came out of
there and before me
jim gaffigan went to georgetown so
there's a whole wow you had like this
whole
um like chain of uh yeah
comedians that kind of trained each
other came up together
it was just yeah and actually jim and i
were talking the other day because we
last year john and jim and i
did we raised a mil believe it or not we
raised a million dollars
for the georgetown scholarship program
which is for first generation college
students
good for you and and we're doing it
again god willing
in the fall and so jim and i were
conspiring about that the other day so
anyway i
i entered the funniest person on campus
contest at georgetown as a sophomore
and i won and one of the prizes was to
perform at the dc
improv and they showed me who was coming
soon and i looked i saw dave chappelle's
coming and it was
it was before you know this is around
robin hood men and tights you know i
mean it wasn't like he
had he wasn't chappelle show yet yeah
yes and i was like
but i love dave chappelle and i opened
for him he was so nice
and he's you know i find him to be one
of the nicest people i've encountered in
comedy
he's he's an incredible human being and
he has this energy about him but also at
this point like this extended family
um where and and also his real family
but you know so
you go and there's just so much love and
warmth um i remember when i was in ohio
so one of the the camp chapelle t-shirts
and gear so yeah
you were at summer camp yeah um and then
just walking around
uh like the house where there's barbecue
after and
but it just felt like the chillest
uh college house party for adults
that you can imagine and and for me at
this stage too mike
i spent two years running for president
two years plus um
and then uh you know we were all um
isolated for covid and then i went to
dave's birthday party and so it was like
my first
brush of just being like a human talking
to other humans
in years yeah it totally was years
um and they they tested everyone when
you landed so you know there was like a
high degree of
uh like visibility that you know
everyone had a bracelet and like you
know you got tested every day
wow so so there was a sense that uh you
know you could relax a little bit
that's amazing it's interesting like man
you ran for president for
two years and it's like where does the
fire come from
for you to show up every day in a
different diner gymnasium
cafeteria like that is hard
a bunch of strangers you don't know
anybody you got you
you have to bring the energy instead of
them
yeah that thank you for um
recognizing the reality of the situation
one of the things one of my mentors
early in my career in my 20s said to me
that really stuck with me
he said andrew uh
it generally takes five years to know
whether something is going to actually
work
uh so if you're not willing to put five
years into it
then it has no chance and you have no
chance oh that's interesting
wow that's that's profound advice it's
very very big advice
100 true in comedy by the way he said if
you're excellent
maybe four years but like for the most
part you're not gonna know whether it's
working
um until five years in uh and so i took
that advice to heart
and you know i've started a number of
organizations i got run a company
and when i embarked on the presidential
campaign
i said okay hell or high water i'm going
to grind until
uh the voting is on and like god willing
i'll be on the ballot
um and the first thing i did um
well maybe the second or third thing i
did was
call friends and ask them to donate to
my campaign
and as soon as you take money from your
friends
like you'd better [ __ ] follow through
you know what i mean yeah yeah
like and sure for some of them maybe
like the money they donated wasn't like
you know make or break for them or
whatever
um but this is true also in business
where like if you take someone's
money then you gotta bust your ass and
fight it out
and then win or lose at least everyone
who backed you will be like okay like i
see you left your
uh heart um on the field um
and so when i embarked on the
presidential campaign
i looked at the calendar and was like i
am going to bust my tail
as hard as i possibly can uh for the
next
two plus years um and you know try and
get on the debate stage trying to get on
the ballot et cetera et cetera
um so no matter how bad the days got um
like one of the advantages to all of
this was knowing that there's actually a
finite time frame
yeah you know and that's something that
was actually
a huge blessing relative to for example
like a lot of folks who are in your
field
where uh you don't know what the like
time frame is
you know you're just gonna like go and
find it out and and uh and so if i were
to tell you like hey
you're going to have two very very
difficult years um you could probably do
it
because you look up and be like well you
know i've done that you know things like
movies yeah yeah i've done plays yeah
sure two
yeah i see what you mean there's a
finite amount of time
but uh yeah i mean it's really it's
really admirable i mean i
yeah i i feel very lucky and i think my
wife
i speak for my my wife and i after
inauguration that
that we were able to get
someone out of office who is seriously i
was so close too
it was so close who i who i would argue
is the least patriotic
president we've had in the history of
america
and it was so close and it was so close
no it's so close
i mean we got really lucky and also
it was an extraordinary amount of
legwork from people like you know you
talk about someone who
who really took what she was given in
terms of a situation where like stacey
abrams had that
election stolen from her and then
instead of saying
i'm going to run for senate i'm going to
run for president i'm going to run for
vice president she goes no no i'm gonna
try to fix
the voting situation that actually
worked against me in an election i
should have won
yeah and holy cow did we all benefit
from her work because
oh my god you flip the senate um and
campaigning in georgia with
reverend warnock and john ossoff uh
was tremendous like uh and it was made
more tremendous by the fact that they
both won i mean that was like the
greatest thing in the world
and and talking to each of them
afterwards it was so happy mike
oh my gosh wow and
stacey abrams 100 um you know helped
make all that happen i mean if she
doesn't do the work she does then um
probably lose those races
[Music]
all right guys new sponsor alert we got
a new company called blinkist
and these guys are awesome i don't know
if you've seen their instagram ads
that's how i found out about them and
then they wanted to sponsor us i was
like heck
yes i love this app it shortens books
for you into a smaller condensed time
frame so you can
read the takeaways if you don't have
time to read the whole book no
disrespect to authors because sometimes
there are books you definitely want to
read the whole thing but sometimes you
just want those takeaways so
you get the main points of book quickly
and start using that information right
away and 12
million freaking people are using this
thing and there's a massive growing
library of books from self-help to
history to business
all these cool things you want wanna
learn a cool history topic like 19
minute summary
bang i love this app i love because i
can read new books but also go back to
my old favorites
you've got books like becomings on there
for michelle obama you've got the four
hour work week from tim ferriss like you
got a whole bunch of hits on here and
we've got
a deal for you as usual which is
exciting so with blinkist you get
unlimited access to read and listen to a
massive library condensed non-fiction
books
all the books you want for a very low
price so right now
for a limited time we've got a special
offer for yang speaks listeners so go to
blinkist b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
dot com slash yang for free seven-day
trial try it out
and you save 25 off on your new
subscription when you do try it so
that's blinkist
b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t blinkist.com
yang start your free seven-day trial
today and you'll save
25 off but only when you sign up at
blinkist.com
[Music]
it just seems like voting is such a
massive massive uh
challenge that our country is going to
be facing for the next few decades
i'm actually deep into the weeds on this
stuff mike because
um like the closeness of this race
uh really affected me and one of the
things that happened
during this cycle was i supported
several dozen congressional candidates
in um
some districts that frankly were you
know almost certainly going to be one by
republicans
but some that i thought were a
legitimate swing districts in places
like
ohio north carolina yeah texas
california um like western new york
um and uh by and large
uh the democrats lost those races
um and not not by
like a slim margin like convincingly
yeah it was a terrible terrible feeling
mike
like seeing these candidates that i got
to know
um i personally contributed to each of
them and i
did everything i could to help them win
and then seeing them get blown out in
many cases
i'll give you one example of someone
that folks might know
jd scholten who ran for congress in iowa
came this close to beating steve king
who was like this you know oh yeah oh
yeah
like and so everyone loves jd he comes
back and runs again
and loses by like a very wide margin
which was such a shocker
um and so digging into the numbers
around what's happening around the
country
uh like we are going to be faced with
this real
polarization for ever
really like and there are a bunch of
structural reasons behind it
um there's there's this thought that we
have that
uh because of changing demographics like
everything's gonna go blue eventually in
the rest of it right
um but the the way our system is
designed
um you know one thing i saw is that
republicans right now represent
42 percent of americans by population
but
like 50 of the senate or you know that
is an example just of course
because you have less populous states
yeah um
and so there are these real structural
issues that are going to get worse not
better
uh and um one of the things i think can
help
and i'm going to be making the case for
this in a very big way maybe you'll help
me maybe i can convince you that this is
like
like an answer is rank choice voting
i completely agree with ranked choice
voting it's the best way
for the most reasonable
and popular candidate to win if we get
ranked choice voting out to enough
places i think there's a chance that we
can bring people back together
because right now the polarization
dynamics are getting stronger not weaker
and i'm happy to say that there are a
couple of states now that have ranked
choice voting
um maine and alaska yeah the maine yeah
yeah i was gonna say maine
alaska just got it way to go oh that's
good that's good
you know what was tough mike and i hope
this changes uh your native
massachusetts actually voted on it in
november
um and it did not pass but i'm convinced
it didn't pass because there wasn't
enough education
uh behind it about it yeah yeah because
people just you know that
so uh so ranked choice voting is a
system where every
voter shows up and you can rank
typically um any of your
top three candidates sometimes it's top
five sometimes it's top three
um and then uh if
no candidate gets over 50 of the uh
first choice
because if if over 50 of people chose
someone in the first choice then they
win
in any system that's right that's right
um but if no one has 50
on the first vote then what they do is
they look at the candidate with the
least number of votes
and then they look at those votes and
then they say okay who's your second
choice
yeah and then they reallocate uh those
voters to their second choice
and then they repeat the process until
someone breaks 50
percent or 50.1 percent um and and this
has so many positive effects
uh it makes it so that you can vote for
whoever you want and there's no worry
about like wasting your vote or
being a spoiler so if you really like
that person you just go ahead and put
them first and then put the other person
second
um it diminishes the incentives to
uh negatively campaign because if i
trash you then we both
kind of look terrible and then this
third place person oh that's nice i
never thought about it that way
yeah like you said it actually rewards
folks that are more about building
uh broad appeal and consensus and less
like people
that are um extremists or flamethrowers
if there was rank choice voting
um during let's say for example the 2016
republican primary
trump does not win um as an example well
because over 50
of the folks that were looking at him
were like like it was like very much
binary where it was like yes trump or no
trump yes but if you like stack together
all of the no trumps
uh he probably does not become the
nominee so
so that that's an example of something
that ranked choice voting can facilitate
and it makes our
democracy more dynamic more responsive
more genuinely representative of the
preferences of voters uh makes it so
that
smaller candidates have a better
fighting chance because
you know like again there isn't like a
waste your vote argument
um so i'm a huge fan of this and i'm
actually going to be trying to make it
happen in more states aside from maine
and alaska
because there are 25 states where you
can actually just have
a uh bunch of signatures and uh and have
like a vote on it
wow that's incredible yeah
it's really exciting yeah so so if we
get it out to
more of these states and then if you're
in a state that doesn't have it you're
like wait why are these other people
have this cool voting system and
yes like that yeah that kind of you know
and then you can just peer pressure
yeah more and more energy around it so
this is going to be a big mission of
mine because i think it can help
reduce the polarization that's kind of
structurally baked in at this point
speaking of another state that's cool
and underrated
i would say alaska i have not spent as
much time there
tell me more mike so like alaska
has a few towns that are spectacular i
mean
fairbanks seward i mean there's some of
the prettiest places
you've ever seen in in i mean the
the seward the seward national highway
which runs from anchorage to seward it's
uh
wildly uh scenic and spectacular
and it's just you know they say they
always have these you tore
alaska and they have t-shirts that say i
think the last frontier
and and it really it you really do feel
like that when you're there you go like
i can't believe this is also part of
america
i feel that way but there's a there's a
handful of other places like that
montana's like that
wyoming is like that there's a handful
of places in america you just go
i can't even believe this is also this
is also we have this
and i find the people in alaska to be
very sweet and i
and they also by the way lo you know
underrated states maine
maine's a great state it seems like
you're a nature lover
um i do yeah i love it the main thing i
i know about alaska is that everyone
there gets uh
you know 1200 a year in oil money from
yes
because that's like a pretty that's like
the original universe yeah
i was making all the time was like look
doing in alaska oil money everyone gets
it everyone loves it
um and and so then i was making an
argument that like
data is the new oil like yes you know we
can do this for everybody
the universal basic income to me
it felt like this thing where for the
first time
someone's saying something that's so
obvious
and yet no one's saying it yeah and it
seemed
obvious and yet uh very
marginal at the same time but then the
marginal became mainstream
over time in part because of the
terrible circumstances
i think that's right and i think like
i think you did a huge service to the
country
by making that a mainstream discussion
point
because and that's why i was always
drawn to your candidacy
because i was like i was like
finally someone brings up a thing that
hasn't been
a discussion point for 30 years and just
says you know what let's take seriously
this idea that
robots are robots are taking our jobs
a lot more than immigrants are taking
our jobs yeah we're seeing it now with a
pandemic
i mean uh think about all the things
we're doing remotely and technologically
i'm really grateful that we're able to
mainstream cash relief and as we're
having this conversation now mike
85 of americans are for cash relief
during the pandemic
55 are for recurring cash relief forever
otherwise known as universal basic
income
yeah uh we already got checks of 1200
and then 600 and they're looking at
another 1400
yeah there are dozens of members of
congress who are like looks let's just
do this ongoing
um and on the flip side you have the
servers that you're trying to help
and like the food lines for miles yeah
all over the country so this is really
a time when the solution is right to
meet the need
and i'm grateful to everyone who
supported my campaign and helped
drag this set of ideas into the
spotlight because
it was very uh touch and go for a while
you know like when i was running in 2018
it wasn't like everyone was like yeah
like let's discuss this no totally and
it was like
it was it's so funny because there was a
point at which
it's obviously so contentious i can't
even imagine
the kinds of sort of like insults and
things people have hurled at you
in the social media space because
people hurl stuff at me for saying
positive things about
you like oh really mike thanks for
sticking up for me i appreciate it
certainly social media um like
is sometimes not the place where you go
to feel good about yourself
i'd say almost never
all right so a certain media outlet had
a headline the other day that said
yang and zach are hawking bidets
on their podcast and i'm gonna say this
you're damn right we're hawking but days
whatever the heck that means this
episode is brought to you by hellotushi
and hello toshi's freaking awesome
here's think about bidets guys they're
better for the environment you save
paper hello tushy
has a really awesome simple contraption
that makes it really easy for you to
have one in your own home andrew and i
are pretty pro anything that helps the
environment and saves paper
so it's a great thing and by the way
almost every other country has figured
this out they figured this out in europe
so we are well behind but days
should be the way of the future and if
you come on this podcast we get you
special discounts so if you go right now
little valentine's day present i don't
know what you want to do give the gift
of hellotushi go to hellotushy.com
yang get 10 off plus free shipping
there's a special offer just for our
yang speaks listeners which i love doing
that's like
why we have these products on here give
me something cool so go to
hellotushy.comyang
get 10 off hellotushy.com yang
[Music]
i want your tech silicon valley friends
ears
in terms of like like how can you
bring jobs to michigan wisconsin
ohio i mean what are we doing here these
are great states how can you how are you
not
building you know uh how are there not
offices there how how come there's not a
headquarters there
i have friends who are working on that
very problem um you know that they've
opened some branch offices in michigan
and similar argument why is it that
harvard university has a satellite in
beijing but not ohio
wow especially because harvard is
getting the equivalent of like hundreds
of millions of dollars in tax breaks
from the national government
and i have a feeling that just about
every american would prefer that harvard
actually opened a satellite
somewhere within the continental u.s uh
and absolutely
dubai or weber yeah and by the way like
these states
are phenomenal places to live i've had i
remember talking to
a silicon valley fancy pants person once
about this idea
do you want to name names no way no way
not a chance um the uh but i
but his argument back was
all these all these silicon valley
companies are gunning for the same
talent
like draft picks to get back to your
football analogy they're gunning for the
same
first round draft picks out of out of
these top schools
and it's easier to convince them
to move to the bay area than it is to
convince a move to ohio
and and sometimes they're trying to
draft internationally too it's one
reason why a lot of these companies
actually just set up an outpost
in asia or eastern europe because
they're just trying to get the talent
and they want to
set up shop some place where the town is
willing to come yeah and then sometimes
they'll just go to where the talent is
um but that that is the game um in tech
for sure
uh there's this real winner take all
dynamic um and it means they're gonna
throw money at smart kids
out of certain schools um like i spent
years trying to
counter balance this with my
organization venture for america because
i thought there was going to be this
massive talent drained
um to certain markets and not others and
so i was trying to send folks to
uh the detroit's the new orleans is the
baltimore's the clevelands
yeah spent six years doing that work
that's when i saw the parts of the
country that
uh you know like that uh you and i are
comparing notes on
yeah the other another gem is boise
idaho i always say
oh my gosh they're trying to get uh get
me to come i never made it i'm sorry
boise
i have a funny story about boise which
is there's this great
uh breakfast spot there called goldie's
and uh and and you know when i show up
when i tour
i always uh i try to come a day early or
i come early in the day so i can spend
the day walking around i'm a big walking
per i like to walk the town and sort of
get a feel for it
and uh and that day my flight was
delayed all day
and so i got there just before i went on
stage and so i said
to my tour manager who had gotten on a
different flight
i go what did you do today he goes i
went to this place called
called uh goldie's and they said the
weight was gonna be a 45 minute wait and
it ended up just being 20 minutes
and i was like wow you're a little cocky
about your wait times goldie's
and uh pull it back you know and so then
i walk on stage
and i and i tell the audience in boise
that story as though i had gone to
goldie's
and it killed people laughed the next
morning
i wake up at the hotel
i walk to the concierge i go hey which
way should i walk to go to goldie's and
he goes
you would know that if you had gone to
goldie's yesterday
like you told us you did last night
and i realized at that moment that that
boise
is a is a town that is too small to lie
in you can't lie you can't lie
yeah you can't lie in boys like boise
too small to lie
can't lie there's not enough people you
can lie in new york like crazy
but you can't lie in boise uh so you
started doing zooms for a thousand
people
a number of months ago and that must
have been a real adaptation i'm just
gonna try and [ __ ] from you and maybe
there are some folks who are watching
this that i actually want too
like what are the best practices if
you're actually going to do
a zoom comedy show for a thousand people
because that must be a lift
and i feel like you're one of the only
people maybe on the planet who can pull
it off
so best practices are because i i
directed two
feature films sleepwalk with me and
don't think twice and so the first thing
i thought was
when i saw people doing zoom comedy
shows i thought
let me watch what's out there and i was
like okay the the two problems
are that the the the lighting isn't
great and the sound isn't great
and it was a huge problem and so i was
like okay
i'm gonna call uh i i'm a i like
i play a a recurring character on the
show billions
uh and it's it's actually a venture
capitalist
from silicon valley his name is oscar
langstret
but i've i'd worked with uh the
cinematographer on this show
um named radium and he's a brilliant guy
and he's really nice
and i knew that he had filmed the movie
tangerine
which which i i don't know if it was
nominated for oscars but like indie
spirits and it
was a really beautiful movie and they
shot on iphones and i knew that he had
filmed it
and so i called radium i said hey can i
pick your brain about this
and he sort of explained to me what you
have to do
essentially to hack an iphone with
lenses and this and that
this kind of you know most of it now
back then it was lenses now it's like
apps you know it's like apps are doing
the same thing and
the iphones have gotten so sophisticated
that you're getting an
extraordinary quality and so i took my
brother's
or my office or my brother's office in
providence
and we put like a camera here a camera
here a camera behind me and then a
camera in the
corner and they're all iphones they're
all iphones
and then we hired a cinematographer
friend of radium
this guy matthew wolf we hired him to
remotely
light the the room and so he would go
okay
take your light take a 1k and put it
here
and we go okay you go move to the left a
little okay move to the left a little
you go okay that you know
and we took it took days it's not like
it was easy
it took days but what but just like a
film set or a tv set
once it's done and by the way this isn't
it this is
this is that this is yeah yeah this is
me in the home i concluded yeah
he's telling me about another this is me
yeah this is the home office setup
uh but uh what yen speak doesn't warrant
the real thing mike
where is the quality lighting and the
sound uh
i do i've one ring light right here
which is actually quite extraordinary
yeah me too man my ring light makes me
feel like i
i delivered for the people yeah so uh so
anyway we did that
and then we just invested in um you know
just some decent microphones
some decent wireless microphones and
then we did a lot of
we hired a sound a brilliant sound
technician this guy jody elf
um who works in uh you know on and off
broadway to
calibrate the levels on the microphone
so that the sound would be just right
and uh and that's all it takes i mean
it's like it's not
that hard it's just a lot of leg work up
front
and then basically it's
don't touch anything once you have the
lighting in place
and your levels are in place just don't
touch it
uh but yeah and and and i have to say
like
my friend sam morill is a comedian he's
the one who said
you should try it and the reason and the
convincing argument
this is way back in june i was like ah
doesn't seem like it's for me it feels
like a hell gig to use the word that i
used in my vulture article and he said
he goes you know what's really
interesting he goes
the people who show up aren't just
people
who are homebound from covid
there are people who are homebound just
from
medical conditions in their life to
begin with
who would never go to a comedy show ever
and i thought oh well that's reason
enough i mean i
then i should try argument yeah i mean i
should try to crack this because
if we're if there's a whole group of
people who have medical conditions that
are keeping them away from live
performance
let me let's try to crack live
performance like why not
so what is the experience like relative
because
uh must be very very different
performing for
iphones that are mounted in various
places yes is
uh you know a live audience um do you
now feel comfortable like you know and
how would you compare one experience the
other
so we have sort of like around the room
off camera
is like there's like an ipad there's a
screen that has
like the zoom participants and so
in different eye lines i can see groups
of people
it's so interesting so i'll go like hey
judy i can see that you have a rabbit
you know and then i go like you're doing
crowd work remotely
yeah and so i'll go like judy like like
is that a guinea pig or a cat you know
and then she'll and then the the
moderator will put her on with me
so we're split screen and she'll go oh
it's actually a it's a cat that sort of
looks like a guinea pig and we call her
guinea or whatever
you know and then next thing you know
you're connecting with people who are
literally across the world i mean five
continents
of participation participants probably
30 countries i mean like
this has been it's don't get me wrong
it's a hell gig it's
hard it's like it's it isn't easy these
aren't ideal conditions
but there is a sense of community and if
you look at my instagram if you go to
applebegs and you look at my instagram
in the comments
underneath the little video clips of the
shows you see people being like
this is the most i've laughed during the
pandemic it made me remember what it
feels i mean
i i i get choked up it makes me remember
what it feels like to laugh
wow that's amazing mike imagine being
able to bring that to thousands of
people
yeah we keep we keep chipping away and
trying to figure out like how do we make
the sound better how do we make their
sound
better you know from their laughter
because we can hear i can hear their
laughter coming in
we have them all set their levels to 20
percent and then like if someone has
like a dog barking or whatever
our moderator shuts off that sound um
channel
and uh it's a whole i mean it's this
this organization called nowhere comedy
club and i think they do an amazing job
so how many people are working on your
show
like in real time when you're there
before simultaneously probably about 10
to 15 people
wow that's what it is wow
yeah but there's they're actually an
outfit that does it for
other performers nowhere club so they do
samurail
i mean it was funny because i got an
email from gilbert godfrey today saying
like what do you think of these things
and
and
and i i i i talked to a lot of comedians
about
the experience because comedians don't
want any part of it they're sort of like
what is that
that seems horrible and and the truth of
the matter is
like sam morrell originally told me oh
scholar brothers are doing it
um you know the truth is
there's a reward in it that is
not what you expect but is totally worth
it
this is wonderful mike it seems so
entrepreneurial and human and solutions
oriented
and artistic um i'm super pumped about
it
and it sounds like i'm sure there are a
lot of folks here
um that want to experience this
so and i know you've been working on any
number of projects over the last number
of months
how can people either attend this show
see what you're up to because you're a
creative powerhouse like you probably
have several things you're working on
well thanks man um if you go to
burbigs.com which is b-i-r-b-i-g-s
dot com which is my nickname uh that has
tickets to
all six shows valentine's weekend
again the valentine's day date i know
you're perfect for valentine
give your significant other a treat oh
it's great and it's you know it's
perfect for
i always say it's perfect for for people
who have a date or people who don't have
a date
and want to have a thousand dates
because it's it really is sort of a
communal thing and then my podcast is
working it out
which is on apple podcast and like this
week we had frank oz
you know we've had ira glass we've had
maria bamford i mean
like uh like a mullany sort of a
murderer's row of comedians and artists
um and we work out new material because
obviously i don't have an audience
and so i want to keep creating and and
work on new material but uh
yeah and i but this has been great i
really have i've really enjoyed talking
me too mike yeah again you're you're
such an activist and artist and creative
force such a pleasure for biggs.com who
knows maybe
uh my wife and i will show up and we'll
be part of you valentine's day crowd
i do owe my wife approximately 1 000
dates
we are doing by the way we're doing
we're doing thursday friday
saturday sunday and i feel like we do
this thing called the slow round
so like for example like on my podcast
every time we do it in the virtual shows
too
so we do a question like a memory from
childhood like do you have a
for example like do you have a memory
from childhood that's always a little
on a loop in your brain but that you
never tell as a story
do you have anything like that my
brother was climbing a tree and then he
got his like legs stuck
in the tree um and then for whatever
reason i found it really funny
and uh and then but he was very upset
and then the people we were with helped
him
free his leg um i did not help i was
you know being a brat and then when he
got down he beat the [ __ ] out of me
that is uh that is a perfect slow round
answer i feel like i'm gonna email you
and hit you up
to be a slow round participant on the
valentine's weekend
and maybe you maybe you have some kind
of romantic story maybe about meeting
your wife or something like that
i'm sure i could i i could uh serve up
something
thematically appropriate um that seems
great
well mike such a pleasure
congratulations on bringing joy
uh and heart to so many people and uh
you know like i can't wait to see what
you do next
um been a big fan of yours for a long
time a big admirer
and i have a feeling uh folks can see
why just from this conversation
uh so thank you brother i hope you and
the family are doing great
same to you andrew and i i really admire
what you've what you've been doing and i
can't wait to see what you do next and
hopefully we can
you know team up on some stuff would
love that let's team up let's do it mike
it's gonna be like super hero crossover
i'm marvel you're dc i'm
x-men you're teen titans i don't know
you kept making my version smaller than
yours
totally arbitrary you could have been
the other way around
i'm superman you're superman's dog
you're astro
i don't know
[Music]
you